why would they let us sell the iphone
there um
i'm curious well
one of the reasons that they have
allowed uh american hardware companies
to operate in china is because
american companies hardware companies
are
operating china under the condition that
they form
joint venture partnerships that a lot of
the times are
a vehicle for transferring and handing
over
valuable intellectual property to local
chinese companies
and obviously hardware is an integral
part of china's broader manufacturing
and industrial plans
so there are some broader macroeconomic
agenda for
why apple as well as companies like
tesla for example have been allowed to
operate in china
so your belief is they're allowed to
operate there because one
they need the jobs china needs to employ
over a billion people
this is their acute achilles seal
correct
that's right so they need the jobs but
they also want all of that ip so by
going there you're essentially
handing over your ip in order to get
access to the market that's that's the
condition
that's being met is that correct you
have to form a joint venture
and the joint venture inherently comes
with the expectation
that you are going to be essentially
transferring
a lot of know-how a lot of technical and
institutional knowledge
um to the to the local partner which is
tantamount to basically handing over
your ip